it is important to do your job with
purpose many people listening right now
do not work 9 to5 many people listening
right now maybe most don't work just 8
hours a day they work 9 or 10 or 11 or
12 I couldn't tell you the last time I
worked 8 hours a day but then again I
can't tell you the last time I worked
because my job doesn't really feel like
work some of the time it feels like work
but a lot of the time it doesn't because
I'm doing something that I feel is
purposeful and has a meaning and I enjoy
it or at the very least even I'm not
actively enjoying it at any given moment
I'm deriving some deal of satisfaction
and gratification from it and this can
be true of any job you can consecrate
any kind of work even the sort of work
that Elites would sneer at and say is
meaningless or drudge work or menial uh
no you can consecrate that work to God
you can find profound meaning in that